9 so only Wilt Chamberlain and Oscar
Robertson were the two others to post
those numbers for a playoff series as
colleagues and you could stop John here
the second time in the series that the
teams have come together
we saw it with
and in a scanner in game 2
give them a shout a shell break they're
kind of
throw it all away
Christian licking much and got in their
columns and Turner
[Applause]
there's one thing about zack collins and
portland fans notice well he is not
afraid to stick his nose into any
scuffle
[Applause]
not sure what they're talking about that
just two free-throws for uh for Yogesh
let's get out with playing basketball in
a 20-point Denver lead they'll go to the
video I say you know he didn't like this
right here where Leonard just kind of
gives them a shove I think yoga shot
that was excessive but official no
hostile look at life the hostile act
okay I mean you play a basketball these
are gonna happen you know that's not
looking at these replays here Collins
yes just got enough of it a block
otherwise you're looking at a potential
and one yeah but the three officials
Mark Davis Tony brothers Josh tivon had
a